can you recall some days when you and
Mark maybe did some cold calling and
that you know I mean I've been there and
it's like you end up putting your foot
in your mouth and they can almost tell
that you're like an amateur and then
there's other times when you're not as
desperate so to speak yeah yeah when it
just flows yeah I mean well mark and I
have been desperate most of our lives so
we can totally relate to that but you
know for us we really didn't make
anything that we thought was really good
until our mid to late 20s and you know
we got our butts kicked back and forth a
million times we never did any cold
calling but we definitely you know we
were honestly we kind of just got
knocked back into a place where it was
like all right we're just gonna make
some five-dollar movies now and we're
gonna see what happens and and we ended
up just getting one of those really
cheap movies into Sundance and people
loved it and we found that the best
thing to do is just to make your stuff
and make it as best as you can at the
level that you can make it at and it
will speak for itself it's very hard to
make something unique and new and good
and once you do that we found that the
doors open themselves for you and people
ask you to you know make more stuff I
mean by the time we made three short
films Sundance was asking us repeatedly
when are you gonna make a feature and we
were like wow we just got invited
basically to make a feature because they
wanted to see that from us and you know
the industry was saying the same thing
to Jay to anyone else who wants to pitch
their own show ideas to HBO or another
cable outlet does it take certain
connections or can anyone just off the
street Cole call HBO and just set up a
meeting I don't I don't know for sure
but I imagine it's pretty pretty tough
to get your your foot in the door at
like a fully established network if you
don't have a body of work behind you the
kind of suppose that you know you can
carry a movie or carry a show from
beginning to fruition but I still do
believe that anything can happen
that you know most people are looking
for inspired new ideas I think that the
tricky part of that equation is they're
also looking for an inspired new way to
execute it and so that's just as much
what they're looking for as an inspired
idea so you know might might take a
little a little history to get you in
that door why are we seeing all this
young talent yourself included Shawn
Durkin Cary Fukunaga Lena Dunham and
others turning to cable TV and other
outlets for their work well I can't
speak for other people but for us you
know the the main reason that we've
recently turned to HBO is is you know
for one we had a we had an idea that
that we thought was more appropriate for
long-form just something that we could
carry out forever and we could do really
subtle amazing things so that that's a
huge advantage and I think you know the
other advantages are you know just
having a having regular work and you
know people we're doing a show at HBO
and Los Angeles and people are thrilled
to be living at home and doing a show
that they really love and care about and
for some reason you know I think I think
it's really the viewership that's
driving it people are watching more
stuff on HBO people are watching stuff
on Netflix and on Amazon so it's it's
the scope of distribution is changing
and I think the filmmakers are following
suit gee it was great to see that you've
backed 26 projects or so on Kickstarter
yeah it's really nice to see that your
collaborative like that what are some of
the key factors that determine whether
or not you are going to donate to
someone who's crowdfunding campain god
mainly just if it inspires me you know
and and and I think the other factor
would just be if I feel like this
thing's not going to happen without
personal and you know individual support
so but usually it's just whether I
really want to see this thing get made
or not what did you learn from
crowdfunding last time you launched the
successful campaign for Kevin yeah our
favorite films what did you learn from
that that you're implementing this time
and that you're also staying away from
what worked what didn't Wow hmm I guess
what worked last time is it was just
really personal you know it was just a
personal journey that I was taking with
Kevin at the time you know we were
hemorrhaging money doing it and we
needed support and and so we just
reached out at first to people that who
loved us and we thought would want to
help us get through the journey and and
it ended up you know expanding to so
many more people and it was it was
honestly beyond financially it was more
than anything was just the emotional
support of you know trying to do
something really really difficult and
having people back you on it and and say
like we support you and also this is a
good idea and this is important and we
want to see this we want to see this
happen it kind of gave us that boost in
the heart of darkness to kind of keep
going so I mean how that relates to the
Manson project is you know it really is
a super personal project it was born of
my friendship with J Davis who's the
director who you know has a weird
fascination with the Manson Family and
has since he was a kid in the in the yin
and yang between all the horrible things
that they did and also but also the you
know the message is a lot of the
messages are positive that they put out
there and they have an environmental
organization and it's it's not totally
one-sided and and I have always been
very disturbed by Jays interest in
Manson and we've talked about it a lot
and that's kind of how this project
began and so it started really was born
of our friendship and
you know two blocks away at Colombo's
restaurant he told me he was gonna write
a script and he wanted me to play the
brother who was going to be skeptical of
the other brother who was into the
Manson Family and I was like I don't
really act that much but I'm gonna do
this I didn't it was one of those
feelings that I had similar to like you
were to you know I was describing to you
about backing a Kickstarter project it
was truly just I was inspired by it I
didn't understand why but I just knew I
needed to do it and backtracking a
little bit you were one of the first
names that put their toe in the
Kickstarter water I mean you were before
is that Graff Rob Thomas Spike Lee James
Franco how did that feel because I mean
definitely being new to that and we've
seen there's a lot of backlash there
yeah two camps there's people that think
who you shouldn't have the right to and
then there's others that say why not
yeah and how was that for you were you
just at a point where you're like you
know what we're hemorrhaging money what
else could we we lose or was it a little
bit there was some trepidation on your
part yeah there's definitely a little
bit of trepidation but you know for the
Kickstarter campaign we did for Kevin we
were only asking for $15,000 and it was
really about as much as finishing the
documentary is about supporting Kevin
getting out into the world and I had
always felt with Kevin that I mean since
I first saw him when I was 20 years old
part of my life's mission subconsciously
was to like help the world know about
him and there was just a certain point
in time where I realized that the it it
wasn't that calculated it was just like
oh this Kickstarter thing could start
that process right now and can help us
finish what we started so it was very
organic process and I felt I guess I
just felt really comfortable honestly
that it was coming from such a place of
love and support for him and what we
were trying to do together and and I and
I feel similarly about the you know the
Manson family vacation project is it's
this is such a personal movie for J
Davis it's it's it's something that's
been brewing in him for 40 years now and
I just it's in it's a really special
movie that
you know we could do a lot of things
with this movie to kind of you know I
don't know make it more typically
commercial or whatever needs to be to
get more traditional funding but this is
really a very personal dark funny you
know artistic movie that you know we
feel very strong about how we want to
make it and we're not asking for a ton
of money we're just asking to make it
the way that we feel like is best and
and so I feel good about it I feel like
it's an important thing to do Jay in the
synopsis for Manson family vacation it
says it's a story about feeling lost in
society in our families as well as in
our jobs yeah can you touch on how this
is so for the character of Conrad as
well as for Nick Morgan who seems to
have sort of the perfect life how is he
lost in society yeah it's I think you
know at first it's very clear that
Conrad the adopted brother that Lynne is
Phillips is going to play is the lost
guy you know he's he's pretty much
borderline homeless right now and he's
just searching for something and in the
back of his mind this there's a Manson
connection something about the Manson
Family is drawing him forward and that
that's you know he's a wayward soul and
that's pretty obvious but I think what's
special about the movie is his brought
his brother who I play Nick who's a
lawyer lives in Los Angeles his life is
very on the rails seems to have it all
together but you know you start to
realize throughout the movie that he's
really lost to and and and that you know
in today's day and age where families
are broken up and people live in
different cities you know there's people
tend to undervalue the importance of
family and the importance of maintaining
those connections and and fighting for
those connections as difficult as they
may be there it's hard to describe and
articulate perfectly but there's
something magical and emotional and
spiritual about about keeping people
together
that that prevents you know drastic
moves like terrorism joining the Manson
Family you know it really glues people
together and holds them to what really
matters why do you think audiences love
stories about lost wayward souls or
maybe that's just myself I mean yeah
like Lynn s played Venice in
bass-ackwards and again and a similar
character and also is it ret and puffy
chair yeah just so these similar these
sort of lost souls that maybe we all
sort of identify with in some way what
do you think it is that we want to root
for these people but at the same time we
condemn them in society ya know it's
interesting I don't know why people love
lost souls I think probably because
we're all lost souls and and we're all
searching for things that we find we
don't know where to find these things
and you know we're trying to return to
two places that we've lost in the past
or trying to find things that we think
are out there maybe they aren't but I I
feel lost all the time so that's why I
connect to it at least when Jay pitched
you the idea for the story
how long before he actually cut this
great video together and put up the
Kickstarter campaign it was a while back
when he pitched it to me was probably a
year and a half ago and he worked on the
script for a long time and I helped him
with it and we just kind of you know
birthed it out of our friendship in the
in the contrast between our feelings
about you know man the Manson Family and
also our own families and and you know
the difficulties and attractions therein
and once we sort of got Lennis on board
we decided to record a video because we
knew that we were going to need all the
help we could get I think Jay talks
about in the video that he works
managing other editors at a
post-production house or he's also an
editor as well yeah you know it's
interesting because it's one thing to
say I can't work 9:00 to 5:00 and I know
a lot of creative people that do that
yeah and I can't work in an office for
someone else and then there's a lot of
people in LA you know they do have that
mindset yet
they may never make it in the film
industry and I'm not talking about J's
specifically I'm just talking about
people in general how do we know or
maybe there is no way to know but the
entertainment career there's no set path
it's not like it has the LSAT you take
the C best and you're in you know pretty
much the worst path in an entertainment
career is to assume that there's a set
path and to follow that by rote if you
do that you're pretty much definitely
not going to make it but yeah it and go
ahead oh no it's perfect yeah I mean but
but you know and then you can do the
cliche Oh on faith you know and I'm
gonna fall you know all that but but
there's a lot of stories of people that
they never turn that corner and and
unfortunately time has passed them by
and they haven't put effort into other
things yeah and then the stark reality
happens where you look around and maybe
you're not where you want to be yeah so
what if someone came to you and said
look I want to follow this entertainment
career path but there is no set path
what do I do knowing that I may never
cross over what would you advise them I
think the most important thing about
following an entertainment career path
is is that you can't follow a path and
and and that's you know that's why I'm
supporting this project and want to be
in in it it's you know my friend Jay
he's not trying to make a career move
he's the story was in him that had to
come out in it and there was nothing he
could do about it and this movie was
going to happen come hell or high water
and and and I think that's what moves
people that's what moved me to be a part
of the project and that's that's what's
moving people to support it and you know
we have all these producers who are
working on the movie for free because
they feel that energy they feel that
passion they feel the need for this
thing to be born and I would just
encourage everyone you know to not think
about their career but to think about
what it is that they want to give to the
world and I think if you think in those
terms things will unfold and everything
will will will sort of like filling
around you because there is no path she
what's amazing about you and Mark is the
amount of press that you guys have done
over the course of your career have you
ever thought about the number of
interviews you've done and the impact
that it's had no I've never thought
about the number of interviews or the
impact at all you know we just we try to
help and to share what we're going
through and we struggles so much in our
20s that we just feel like if people
want to ask us questions and hopefully
it can help them in any way that it's
it's you know it's our duty to do that
and to give back but you know I I don't
really think about what's out there you
know how it impacts people I do I do get
some feedback that people appreciate it
and it's really nice do you subscribe to
the idea that there is no such thing as
bad press or I mean we're seeing things
sometimes in the media where I go hmm
is this orchestrated or is this really
the story and now I think more so than
ever yeah I'm so removed from that world
and from the concept of like doing press
stunts or anything you know it's just
not I don't have the time or the brain
space to do it I got two kids and I'm
trying to make a decent movie and I find
those two things to be just unbelievably
difficult to do at the same time so I
don't I don't think that much about bad
press and I I personally just thinking
about it right now I'm just like I fall
on the side of I believe in karma and I
believe in telling the truth and and in
doing what you believe in and and not
lying and not and not faking anything so
you never have to watch your back I mean
that's that's my that's my philosophy of
life and and an art and and everything
honestly so I'm sure it probably works
for some people but
it's not for me what about the terrence
malick approach where you know nothing
and then you're totally fascinated just
beyond belief because there's no
information I'm fascinated by Terrence
Malick so absolutely yeah I definitely
I'm a private person so it definitely
appeals to me
to be like a Coen Brothers type person
or like a Terrence Malick type person
but you know like I was telling you
before like you know young filmmakers
look up to us and they want to know how
we're doing what we're doing and and
when I hear that and I feel that I feel
moved to share it you know and to share
our process and and to try and help
people express themselves because it was
you know the hardest journey of my life
was to you know sort of like come out
with like who I am and what I want to
give to the world and if I can help
anybody get through that then that's
something that I would love to do for
any filmmaker who would love a career
that the two of you have had a what kind
of work would they be prepared to put in
and be what kind of sacrifices would
they have to make
that's that's a good question
I don't think that you can approach what
mark and I do as with the idea of having
the kind of career that we have I think
the only reason we have the kind of
career that we have is because we just
make stuff and we have always just made
stuff and made stuff that we think is
new and special and and is uniquely ours
to give you know
and luckily other people want to watch
that stuff and networks and studios are
willing to pay for that stuff now but it
took a good 12 years before anybody
wanted to watch it or pay for it and I
think the only reason we're here is
because we love doing it and we love
each other and we it's just it's almost
like a can't not do it type of thing and
you know we were lucky enough to to have
it have it be supported now I mean it's
happening with Joe Swanberg right now I
mean Joe made movies from love and made
tons of them because he loved it and he
loved the process and he loved creating
with other people and sharing it and
exposing himself in every way and and
now he's supported you know and I think
that's it's not really a model but I
guess it is you know it's you can't want
it for the career you gotta want it for
the love of it in the art of it and you
got to be willing to do it whether you
get paid or not so it sounds like to
that same idea going back to that
conversation you had a year and a half
ago with Jay Davis about his idea that
he just could not not do it yeah I do
yeah I mean Jays not making the Manson
family vacation because he thinks is a
good career move it's actually a bad
career move for him because he's like
you know he's doing another job and he's
got two kids and it's it's you know it's
a really big strain on everything in its
life to try and pull this thing off he's
doing it because he loves it and he has
to do it there's something inside of him
that's trying
you know and and and that's I relate to
that process that's been the process of
my entire career and and you know it
just so happens that I love the idea and
I love what he's doing so it's it's easy
for me to get behind it and support it
why do you think the media loves
covering the films that the two of you
make you don't seem to make big
Hollywood action films yes right now
I've become sort of mainstay but people
relate to your quirky characters and the
interesting storylines what do you think
that is where does that come into play I
don't know I don't know what it is I'm
so glad people like to watch our stuff
or and in particular I don't know what
it is but press loves that may press
tends to love our stuff I really don't
know what it is I mean all I can say my
sprinklers are coming on all I can say
is that you know you know we're just I
think it has something to do with the
fact that the stories that we're telling
our very private personal stories that
mark and I are sharing with the world
and I think people feel that and I think
they relate to it because we're I guess
we're telling stories on a we're going
to another level of realism or at least
we're trying to do that you know and
that's what we've heard in terms of
feedback is you know not just audiences
but press as well like oh man that's
scene with this those guys in the
bedroom it was like you had a microphone
in my bedroom last week they were like
you know and and and it's not like we
have figured something out or whatever
it's just we're really we're trying to
tell the truth of what it means to be in
relationships right now and and how it
really feels and I think I'm just so
glad that people are feeling it you know
Jay right now we've only known you so
far as someone who works behind the
scenes behind the camera with the
scripts with the story with all that how
is it for you to star in someone else's
independent film
feel about that terrifying starring in
someone else's film is terrifying but
but also incredibly exciting and you
know I've always been actually shooting
all of our films and people are like why
aren't you ever in it everyone you know
is in your films but you know it's it's
literally because I'm looking through
the lens but I'm excited about the
opportunity and it feels very natural
and it feels positive and you know both
of these characters the the Nick
character and the Konrad character are
kind of two sides of my really good
friend Jay Davis and I know him so well
it's so easy for me to like lock into
that and do that and I'm just really
excited to explore it it's been
something that you know I came up acting
in Austin Texas with my brother Mark as
well it just kind of fell into place
that I was shooting and he was acting
for a while so has Mark influenced
anything with this project in terms of
you being in front of the camera did you
tell him about it
yeah Mark's just been you know he's
gonna executive producer with me and
support me through it and and more than
anything he's just been super supportive
of me you know trying something new and
and kind of coaching me through the
process in terms of getting this project
up and running and and um you know
because he's had a lot of experience
acting in executive producing movies and
so he's been great about it and you know
just honestly believing in me and and
that's that's everything
what advice would you give to actors
working with directors let's suppose
there's someone fresh off the bus from
somewhere else in the country what would
you tell them about what it's like to be
on set how they should conduct
themselves is it okay to give
unsolicited feedback I mean what yeah
how should someone be on set for actors
working with directors I would just say
for everyone on set in terms of the
creative positions just just to be
really honest and open and vulnerable
and express your fears and and and and
and but also to try to be courageous and
bring your best you know I mean it's
it's like the deepest tenets of making
art you just have to do it socially and
publicly when you're making a film which
is which is hard you know but that's
that's all I would say do you remember
the moment when filmmaking was no longer
a dream
and it had actually become a reality for
you remember do you remember that
realization or I've had several stages
of realizing that it's still happening
sometimes I wake up in the middle of the
night and I'm like wow I'm being paid to
make movies that's good that's right
that's a good thing but honestly that
that one click never really there was
never really one click of the dream is
now a reality and I think it really has
to do with the fact that I guess I've
always known subconsciously that it's
all about just making stuff it's all
about just making art and you can do
that whether or not someone's paying you
to do it you can it's just something
that you do and I've always done it so
in a weird way this has been going on
since Mark and I were kids
we're just happen to be doing it at
studios in an HBO right now and it
sounds like - it goes back to what you
said there's no set path yeah there's no
set path yeah
and it almost seems like is it some way
a curse to kind of say okay yeah I've
made it and because in in Hollywood
whether it's whatever job it is whether
you're makeup artists whatever you're
only kind of as good as your last job
yeah I don't feel like I've made it at
all and I don't I don't know if anybody
feels like they've made it because you
could easily never do another movie
again no one will guarantee you a movie
even if you have a three-picture deal
with the studio they're not necessarily
gonna make it they're just gonna look at
it you know so I think you know it all
just comes down to you just have to make
your stuff
and believe in yourself and and and keep
doing it you know at any level whether
it's a ten million dollar studio movie
or a $40,000 Kickstarter project Jay how
has financing your earlier films evolved
into how you find money now has it
gotten easier is it still the same
animal it's just a different I don't
know I'm probably not explaining it
correctly but is it easier now or it's
just a different way it's still
difficult
I think financing is always difficult
you know whether you're raising the
money whether you're paying for it
yourself
that adds difficulties that are hard to
explain the pressures of that are
enormous whether it's going to a studio
and getting money ifs to gives you a lot
of money trust me you will feel it when
you're making that that film so I think
it's always hard and it's always a great
responsibility and it's something that I
just because my personality never take
lightly so it's always like with me but
that's why I think it's just important
to whoever you're you're collaborating
with whether it's you know actors studio
people investors whatever it may be you
have to meet minds with them and feel
that connection so that everyone's on
the same page trying to make the same
thing and and that's I mean it's
interesting it's kind of a metaphor for
the theme of the movie
is is like you know creating family and
and and creating that special nest to to
do to do the bold and courageous things
that you want to do in your life did you
invest your own money with the puffy
chair and bag head yeah
you do so you showed you know people
that you had your own skin in the game
yeah do you think that's important for a
lot of people because so many people
they say oh use other people's money
don't use your own but don't you think
in the beginning that's probably the
best way to prove that you're willing to
invest in yourself and take a risk yeah
it's I think it's I think it's helpful
to invest your own money into whatever
projects that you're doing you know
that's something that I've always done
and that I believe in and I would never
be a part of a project that I wouldn't
be willing to invest in as well
but I do think especially in the
beginning it green lights your projects
and it makes them go faster you know and
it allows you to explore and it gives
you the freedom to be yourself and to
take more chances you know so the more
because I think the most difficult thing
about making a piece of art is really
like figuring out what you're trying to
express and to do it in a truthful
manner and if you have a lot of voices
in the room before you really know who
you are
it might be hard to figure that out
where does someone go to figure that out
movie sets and just be sort of in the
background know oh you got to do your
own I mean I just personally believe if
you want to be a film director you need
to just be a film director and there's
no limitations all you need is a 5d in
you don't even need a 5d ya iPhone I
guarantee you if you make a really
fascinating script and shoot it on
iphone people will watch it and your
next film will be bigger you know it's I
think the problem is when people come in
expecting to make Apocalypse Now on
their first go you know it's it's
probably not gonna happen you know you
need to start small and and figure
yourself out and allow yourself the
opportunity to mess up and do it again
if you mess up and also you said know
who you are you would only really find
that out and sort of the heat of the
moment behind the camera with ya whether
it's just two people in a park I think
there's something about our culture that
has us thinking that we can figure out
who we are inside of our heads but
that's not how it happens or at least
that's not how it happened for me I
think the way you figure so yourself out
is by doing things and by being in
relation to other people and as a
filmmaker the way you figure yourself
out is by making things and failing or
succeeding and finishing the film and
showing it to strangers and seeing how
they react to it and how they feel about
it I think that's the only way to to
really figure out who you are and what
you have to offer because if not it's
just inside of your head it doesn't it
doesn't really mean anything in the
greater context of the world but we all
want to just do it in our heads because
it's safer
we interviewed filmmaker ty West
and he said that you know filmmaking is
actually it can be a very painful
process and oh he likes to do
he says he'll just lock himself in a
room or something over a weekend and
flesh out an idea because if he didn't
he would abandon it you can find too
many holes in it yeah how is
screenwriting for you what's your
process is it easier as you finish the
script the process is super complex and
it's evolved over a long period of time
of how to write stuff I definitely agree
with ty that a big part of screenwriting
is is
forcing yourself to just to just create
and to not and analyze and to not put it
into an intellectual space I mean my
brother even talks into a dictaphone you
know but you know honestly I think the
the best piece of advice and the
toughest part about writing something in
my opinion is the first draft and I
called the vomit draft where you just
literally puke up in my opinion the best
thing you can do yourself is just to
write a terrible first draft that's got
to be your mindset it's like what I'm
about to write is going to be horrible
but it's going to allow me to have a
platform to redo scenes to build it up
to give it to my friends let them read
it tell me how to make it better you
know it's just you have to create the
foundation and it's all about getting it
out of your head and onto a piece of
paper because once it's on a piece of
paper now you have something that exists
in the world that you can share with
other people it's not it's a theme that
I've been talking about a lot it's like
really getting out of your head and
making the process getting in it's a
world that's part of Kickstarter like
with Kevin is like before we went on
Kickstarter Kevin and I were just two
guys like wandering around Austin in Los
Angeles and in Spain you know but once
we got people involved it really helped
us coalesce what we were trying to do
because we were getting feedback from
people it's like wow I love just seeing
you guys together that alone is like
really heartwarming so you know the
process of screenwriting is is painful
and enormous and exciting at the same
time but the I just I just suggest you
know just get it on the page and start
working on it do you do that same type
of thing that ty talks about almost
locking yourself in a room for a weekend
and just vomiting out this what you call
the vomit drop just kind of getting it
all out because you saying that you know
if you wait and and think about it you
know you're poke holes in it and you'll
be like you know what actually I've come
up with a better idea yeah I don't I
don't allow myself to go back
when I'm writing something I just forced
myself to go all in a row I don't
necessarily go away to do it but when I
do write I try to get it out as fast as
possible and I and I and I don't look
back it's so tempting to do it but if
you do that you'll start rewriting
you'll start reanalyzing where you're
going I think it's super important just
to keep going and to finish it and then
you can start thinking about it and
analyzing it we've known so many people
that they have all these great ideas
myself included and then they abandon
them because you know what they get
bored with it yeah or I don't know maybe
there's a fear and finishing stuff yeah
I think it's mostly people just get
bored I get bored of ideas all the time
and you know there's a that's a that's a
tricky point to realize like you know a
lot of people have a lot of ideas
spinning in their head and and I think
you know I've only recently come to
really value my own time and like what
I'm going to spend time on it's such a
critical decision which idea you're
gonna execute and I think it's also
important not to let ideas sit too long
you know if they sit too long you're
probably gonna get bored you're probably
going to have churned it enough to where
you don't need to explore it in
screenplay form or in or in filmmaking
form you know and what about that person
that has this amazing idea they're
passionate they're in traffic they can
think of nothing else but it this idea
but then it's Apocalypse Now and it's
their first film what do you say to that
person good luck yeah I mean
it's hard I'm not saying that someone
can't come out of the gate and make
apocalypse and how or make five Easy
Pieces or a great great film but you
know it's real hard to make a 90 minute
piece of art that's worth watching
that's my experience is it's
unbelievably hard and when you if you
can boil it down to the simpler elements
of filmmaking you know I mean it's it's
no coincidence that most filmmakers
start with very very simple films and
then they grow in complexity over time
as they as they become more complex and
they learn more about what works and
what doesn't work and what they have to
offer so I wouldn't discourage anybody
from exploring any idea and you can
certainly do it for free in screenplay
form that's the great thing about
screenwriting but you know I think it's
also important to have to have ideas
that are executable at the level that
you're at and that's that's the most
important thing because it's not about
long shots and you know magic and stuff
Lee it's really just about creating work
that you can share with people so really
have you know maybe you have that
passion but have it be taped something
that you know that you can do in one
room yeah or do to you know do your big
two hundred thousand two hundred million
dollar movie and and then you know make
sure you have a small one to that that
that a couple of friends and some five
days could make with a $40,000
Kickstarter campaign what's your first
seven days working on a new script well
before I write anything I just think
about it a ton and I and I really make
sure that I feel like I have the arc of
the story and the characters and I know
where things are going roughly but you
know once I have that and decide that
I'm gonna take the time and write this
thing the first seven days honestly are
just writing feverishly
in a row without ever looking back so
that I don't have a chance to destroy
the idea before it has a chance to live
that's really what it's about do you do
composites of these characters I mean do
you also do a whole write-up on this
person's life from birth to middle age
or whatever even without putting that in
the script but that you fully know that
character sometimes we do composites of
characters or we'll just think about
backstory but honestly the story comes
first because I think part of writing a
story is is figuring out who these
people are and at least for me the
people are not necessarily that well
defined you may find that the story
needs to go in a different direction and
that that character that you're
originally thought of might not do this
so to me the story arcs and the and the
plotting of the story is also is
malleable as well as the characters are
like everything is this tornado that
unfolds and then once that first draft
comes out back you kind of look back and
then you start figuring out hey I
thought this character was really like
my sister but it's not actually it's
like a blend between my sister and you
know this this girl that I dated or
whatever it may be so I think you know I
just try and leave it open but once
we're ready to shoot we know who these
people are and can probably talk about
them for a long time any tips on
figuring out the ending it seems to be
sometimes a very difficult thing people
have a great finish great middle
I find endings to be easy I do they tell
it tells me the story tells me how it
wants to end the characters tell me what
needs to happen I think the hardest part
for me is the middle is like you know
creating
you know a situation that has real
conflict and real confusion and real
stuff to work through that's not that's
not just cute or convenient for for a
script you know have you researched any
of the quote gurus are you fans of
certain screenwriting teachers school of
thought I don't I don't subscribe to
screenwriting gurus because most of them
have not written great screenplays I do
I do love the war of art that's the one
book that I love yeah because and I
don't think it's a coincidence that he's
a good screenwriter he's one of the few
who you know has really written great
things but to me it's it's it's not
about form and it's not about teaching
you how to do it it's really more about
inspiring you you know and getting you
unstuck and I think that that book has
been super helpful to me